are you familiar with strass how
generational theory no
so we had uh ben stewart on the show and
has a really fascinating conversation
this is
it's a book called the fourth turning
and they talk about how there's four
seasons every 20 years it's a season
there's the springtime
there's the summer the autumn and then
the winter and we are about to hit the
winter season so
the way it goes at every 80 years there
is a massive
upheaval violent war or something like
that right
80 years ago what do we have world war
ii eight years before that what did we
have
civil war eighty years before that what
do we have a revolutionary war
and so they're basically like we're
about to enter this period uh i bring
this up because
everything we're mentioning uh you know
for those that are just tuning in or
just jumping on the segment
we're talking about countries like
scandinavia and you mentioned like after
three generations of
just like i guess everything's granted
to you
we're with prosperity we we become
weakened
and i want to show you the story from
the new york post and i want to bring
this up pentagon
diversity chief reassigned amid probe of
social media posts
i don't care about this guy being
reassigned i care the pentagon
has a diversity chief i keep hearing
these stories about
diversity inclusivity and equity
liaisons and
and czars and chiefs and officers
why do our businesses have ideological
arms or employees to me i know it's not
identical
but it's no different from the communist
party saying if you want to open a
business in china the communist party
needs to have a position
in your company here in the us they're
like well if you're running this company
you need to give our cult a position in
your company
the pentagon has it now i'm sorry man
we've weakened beyond
it's it's perhaps too late in my opinion
i don't know maybe it's not too late
but the generations that came before us
were not paying attention
and they don't care i've talked to
people in the intelligence community and
they tell me
leadership doesn't care they just want
to get home at the end of the day
they want they want to maintain the
status quo whatever pays the bills
they don't care so this is crazy no it
is and
and the role of the pentagon should be
to train
and prepare a force to be
lethal and brutal to defend the country
if need be and hopefully that day never
comes
but that's the only diversity and
inclusion they need they need to be as
diverse and inclusive to the point that
they will
destroy any enemy that faces them and
and
the fact that we're pushing these
sociological or or psychological
philosophies that's just runs counter to
the goal of the military
diversity inclusivity and equity
in terms of the military should be a
diversification of armament
inclusion of different ordinance and
equity
in the amounts that they have across the
board to be able to defeat any threat
not some weird cult-like ideology about
you know training soldiers that the
gadsden flag is racist
and then if somebody has it on their
faces they got to pull them out of their
their their mission in dc yeah military
philosophy is legit but
that's the philosophy of combat and and
confrontation not of how people feel
not really i mean there is the hearts
and minds battle that we're trying to
win and maybe some people think that by
doing this we're gonna
we're gonna get more hearts and minds on
our side but it seems like it's it's
rupturing the system when it doesn't
need to i and i think we've been playing
the military at least has been playing
the hearts and minds game for
20 some odd years i was at state
department long long time ago
um spent time in iraq afghanistan
as part of the hearts and minds war and
for 20 years now we've been saying well
maybe if we just work with the taliban
and build their kids schools and
maybe if we send more of their girls
into jobs trainings
and here we are 20 years later and how
many trillions of dollars more and it's
like and how's that going for us right
we can't get out of afghanistan
even trump couldn't pull out of
afghanistan because the mission isn't
yet accomplished
so maybe the hearts and minds game is
what the military should do maybe the
military should kill all of the enemies
and and i'm sorry to say that and then
what happens after that
that's their problem like if they wanted
to
create like a global arm of goodwill and
they wanted to build water systems and
roads and all these countries across the
world
cool but if you drop bombs on a country
it's going to set the whole process back
20 years
maybe they should be building
infrastructure roads water here yeah
they should
and over there like just do it well they
just did around the the capitol for the
last two months they built a great wall
it was as secure as could be none of the
crazy trucks
no trump supporters penetrated the
capital for for months on end
so i mean they kept saying walls don't
work and they built the wall to keep out
amazing well tom cotton is doing
something about it cotton introduces a
bill to ban
critical race theory teaching in the
military
republicans don't have any power right
now and what the democrats seem to be
doing
right now is they know they have a very
slim
majority and they are pushing as hard as
possible to gain as much power as
possible because they know it won't last
yes come 2022 the republicans will take
the house back and then they will
and probably the senate in 2022 you
think it's 50 50. yeah
are the are there seats up for democrats
yeah yeah and i think
i mean literally you flip two seats and
that's all that that matters i mean
starting with georgia
right one season yeah starting people
starting with georgia um there's
there's a re-election there because it
was a temporary seat right so
so yeah i'm but like you i agree with
you 100 they know they have a two-year
window to enact as many things as
possible
obama did the same thing back in 2009
right he passed health care
because he knew he had one shot to do it
they had a super majority they had to
get it done
they got it done and they lost i'm not
confident
the republicans will be successful i
think there's a lot of people who don't
like the republican party who only voted
republican because trump was something
different he was
actually trying to do things you take a
look at biden right now
did you see that they apparently
rebranded to the biden harris
administration
creepy what is this um i i tweeted about
it and i was like
i was like amazing and inspiring despite
every obstacle from racism sexism to not
even getting a single delegate in the
presidential primary
kamala harris is proving that nothing
will stand in her way and she will
eventually become president
she didn't get a single delegate and now
they're slowly inching towards making
her the president
and it's right there if i didn't get any
delegates in 2008 i don't remember
i don't remember he was up against he
was a nobody in that running though he
was one of the worst guys on stage
in 2000 that's a disgusting great
question how how soon did he draw
you know and i was paying attention
those days also but um
he wasn't i think hillary was was
obama's biggest in 2008 bernie's
no not bernie sanders yeah it was
pre-bernie and i'm sure biden and there
were probably like three or four other
folks out there who
ran who dropped out pretty quickly um
was that also um i didn't get zero
then biden got all this free press being
the vp
yeah and he got made for they would make
fun of him be like oh
joe shut up you know those memes where
like it shows joe saying something
stupid and obama's like oh
yeah that's that was real yeah i think
i think critical race theory in the
military is
it's the demise of the military dude
what you need to understand about
critical race theory is that it's not
actually a theory of anything no
it's basically just one person going
i've decided that
uh water bottles are racist and does
everybody agree
and then someone goes i don't think it's
racist well then you're a racist for
denying it yeah
that's all they do is there's like no
right fine racist oh god ibrahim x kendi
the guy who wrote that
that book um is it how to be an
anti-racist
said that that one of the he said the
heartbeat of racism is denialism
by denying your racism is a sign of your
racism
and that that is kafka right that whole
that whole kafka book that
the trial was about that like if you
admit it you're guilty if you deny it
well only someone who would have done it
would deny it you're guilty
and so so kafka how many hundred dozens
of years ago 100 years ago was like well
this is where we are headed
and that's what critical race theory is
you are racist intrinsically by your
race
and if you deny it it's only because
that is a sign of your racism and there
you go
i think we did that with witches in the
salem witchcraft they throw them in the
water and be like if she's a witch
she'll float
no no no monty python okay that was a
joke
but they're funny those guys if she
weighs as much as a duck
yes right yeah what else weighs ducks
float
what else weighs as much as a duck
churches what small rocks
wood that's right so if she floats and
she weighs as much as a duck which means
she's made of wood
was it a witch is it that they would
burn them alive and if they didn't burn
then they were a witch
i always when they always said a duck
and that the the man said
who are you so wise in the ways of
science i
i reply often on twitter with that when
people like solar panels are renewable
forever and i'm like who are you
so wise in the ways i love that line
i guess this is this is an issue of
people who vote when there's no skin in
the game
yeah you know and so the challenge is
you know uh someone asked me about
they're like well you know you know back
in the day
when people would vote they had to be
landowners because it was about racist
white slave owners blah blah and i was
like i thought the idea was that they
didn't have ids
and so it was like you had to actually
live there and be able to prove you
lived there to vote
and so land ownership proved not only
were you a member of the community
proved you lived there
and that you had skin in the game and a
stake in what this vote represented
the issue now is and i'm not i'm not
saying i i'm actually a fan of
like universal suffrage people having
the right to vote well i should say
universal i don't know that implies it
could be
anybody like dog's vote or something but
uh i i think
you know there's a people should have
the right to vote
we're in a different system but now we
have people who will like
move to new york and then after like a
month they're eligible to vote
vote for something ridiculous and then a
few months later back oh man this is
awful i regret that and then i'll leave
and they just leave the place worse off
there needs to be something
staking your vote like and and you in
this community where
you know that what you do will impact
you otherwise people can come and vote
and then leave
yeah like local like waiting a couple
years before you can vote locally
that got brought up a couple weeks ago i
like that idea and
yeah and so then what happens is we
remember like in this past election
there are a lot of people who are like i
think it was andrew yang got in trouble
because he said he was going to go on
down to georgia and help the democrats
win and people are like yo
and the georgia republicans were like if
you move here and try to vote
he was like i'm not going to do that i'm
not doing that but it was actually a big
issue because people can move
all over the place andrew yang should
run as a republican well i think he
could win 2024
as a democrat for mayor of new york oh
yeah
good luck andrew after having tweeted
multiple times about like leaving the
city and how he hated living in new york
and and he uh i mean he's always had a
condo there or something but he lived
outside of new york and
now he sees this as a viable opportunity
and he's like yeah maybe i'll work okay
mayor of new york's better mayor of new
york yeah republican president because
they want a populist
the republicans love well p the people
that went for trump love a good populist
like
energetic fireball of a personality and
yang i think is
you know he was he was he's got more
mutualist appeal yeah without a doubt
but but going back to the voting thing i
i agree with you in that
we establish thresholds for things for a
purpose and by lowering the threshold by
by dumbing it down to put it
pejoratively
does not do society a service so we've
made it so easy to drive now
right we got rid of a lot of the driving
exam
parallel parking is no longer part of
the driving exam in new york city
wow yeah the k turn is no longer par
well are we making our
roads better it's like well no we're
allowing more people to drive well i
don't want more people to drive i want
driving to be
something that you actually can prove
that you can do same with exams
same with citizenship to a certain
extent and i think voting is the same
way i don't want to lower the threshold
down to get
the the lowest common dominator in i
think we have to keep standards high
look we talked about this with do you
want your medical doctor to be someone
who was like well i you know i did the
multiple choice test
well maybe i want your exam to be a
little bit harder than that if you're
going to
operate on my eyes right maybe you
should pass a certain threshold and
we've lowered the threshold down for
voting to the point that like you said
you can show up to a state same day and
say i live here now
with no id no covet passport though
that's a little different
but with no id with no proof of anything
i want to vote in this election okay you
can vote
why because that's fairness that's
that's not
service guarantees citizenship are you
familiar with that
starship troopers yeah yeah everyone
brings that up
see i don't i don't know if i agree with
that concept but it's interesting it's
an
interesting
concept concept and uh um i guess the
the author got called a fascist
for implying that you you'd have to
serve the community or the country
in order to have the right to vote in
that country i don't agree with that
it's but it's skin in the game of
something right
i think i think there has to be a
standard
required for voting and it was funny i
think i got accused by leftists of
saying you know like tim poole thinks
that
it should be harder to vote and i'm like
i mean it should be
to a certain degree there should be a
standard to vote some kind of thing
where
we don't want people to be laying you
know in on their couch
covered in grease stuck to their sofa
because they've been sitting there for
six months
and they're like i don't want to work
and then they get a letter in the mail
and they're like they pick it up
you know their mom throws it at him and
they're like mail-in ballot
and they open it up and they're like i'm
gonna vote for this guy and send it in
meanwhile there's a guy who's overseas
got his leg blown off in afghanistan his
vote is now negated by this person who
does nothing
and he's risking everything so i feel
like there's got to be at least
you have to get up and go vote yeah and
maybe something more
my general idea is if people want to
vote they need to choose to get up and
go vote
and we even talked about this i think
and i agree we should remove party
affiliation from
from ballots because what happens is
people show up and they're like
r d and then you end up with a bunch of
wackos running the government
which is where we're at right now well
yeah and i think
getting rid of lowering the voting age
the reason why i'm opposed to it is and
i said kind of cruelly like 16 year olds
eat tie pods and and of course i'm
i'm joking but we used to we used to
understand that like
with age somehow came experience came
wisdom came
knowledge and and that can only i'm not
necessarily
but it's more likely to have more
knowledge as an older person than as a
younger okay
because of time right because just
because of time but hold on
then that's an interesting point because
that still could be aegis there's very
wise 16 year olds maybe somebody started
working the family business when they
were seven
so aptitude test how do you do it you
know how do you make sure that people
would be cool if a kid and no offense to
six year olds i know you don't feel like
a kid but legally you're a kid until
2018 um
could take a special test if you're
under 18 and you wanted to vote you
could go apply
take a civic example yeah i want to
clarify that tide pod thing
nobody actually ate tide pods it was a
meme but one kid as part of the meme
put the tide pod in his mouth as a joke
and then his saliva broke it oh no oh
and as soon as he tasted it he
and aspirated to some of the pot and
then spit it out
did he live yeah he's okay permanently
it scarred a ton of his lung tissue
he was not trying to eat the tide pod he
was jokingly
putting in his mouth yeah these things
are dissolved by water like
almost instantly yeah and then he went
and like
inhaled a bit of it don't put tight pots
in your
yeah don't pretend like you're going to
hurt yourself yeah yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 p.m where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you